Conscription is mandatory for every
Egyptian male who has turned 18 years old
The period of conscription is 3 years
This period is reduced to one year only
for university and higher institute graduates
and to two years for medium institute graduates
Draft evasion is punishable
by imprisonment, fine or both
Military parade marches on the army hymn
The Soldiers
Egyptian conscription tales
written by the poet Farouk Jweideh
and composed by the musician Kamal Tawil
On our hearts we engraved the sight of homeland
its palms, Nile and noble people
We protected you, O Egypt, over the time
so your youth remains forever
In the same vein, Colonel General
Sedki Sobhi, Minister of Defense
approved the recruitment of
new soldiers in April 2016
Once you graduate from college
the first impediment to your dream
of doing something with your life
becoming an engineer, a doctor,
a manufacturer or anything
is conscription
It is compulsory, it is not something
you volunteer to do or you like
You only have to do it
to move on with your life
You are here to witness withyour own eyes the
high level fighting capacity of your armed forces
Egyptian President
Abdelfatah Elsisi voice
You are here to witness with your own eyes the
high level fighting capacity of your armed forces
The faces and voices of the soldiers, NCOs and officers
have been hidden and altered for their safety
you shall take pride in
them as the shield
against all those who dare
thwart our nation’s security
and jeopardize the
stability of its people
I am one of the very few who were
really excited about serving in the army
I thought it would be a training session
in military science and combat skills
So I used to think it was mandatory for all Egyptians
Medical examination
Any person deemed medically unfit
is released from their obligation to serve
When you are medically examined, you meet doctors
But you have to keep in mind
that these doctors are officers
You should not expect any sympathy
so, when they tell you to take
your clothes off you obey
You stay in your underwear
You go from one clinic to another
you start with an exam by
the optometrist, orthopedist,
dermatologist and then gastroenterologist
Many pretend they are sick
Some would go with eyeglasses
while they have excellent 6/6 vision
I saw some people faking sickness and being relieved
and some who were really sick and forced to serve
I do not know how to say this… I am sorry…
this might sound strange… but they ask you to bend
Yes, the want to make sure you are a man
They ask you to take everything off to
make sure you are straight and not gay
They examine you directly
The doctor examines you to see
whether you are straight or not
So this doctor probably
examines 500 butts a day
I do not remember if I took my clothes off
I guess I did
I did
but it was fast
he was looking at me from a distance
he was wearing a white coat…
so I guess he was a doctor
but yeah, I took my clothes off
Thankfully I was deemed medically fit
they told me to come in two days
At the end of it, an officer came out
and spoke about the benefits of the army
how we will be fed well
and have a good stay
He concluded by welcoming us in the armed forces
Welcome to the Armed Forces
Training Center
Soldiers are trained in the warfare center
for 45 days before joining the main force
The most important thing is
to be as efficient as possible
If you manage to do that
and ensure a high level of training
high level of ability,
shooting and understanding,
you will get the results WE decide
The main purpose of a training center
is to teach you how to use a wireless radio
transceiver and so on if you are in the Signal Corps
or how to operate a tank
if you are in the Armored Corps
You are taught theory and practice
There is one thing that remains
the same everywhere: shooting
This is what is supposed to happen,
but it is not the case
We were taught how to shoot on the spot
Each one shot the gun 3 times
but without aiming
A Non Commissioned Officer would sit
next to us, because that was our first time
You pull the trigger for 3 shots without aiming
They do not care if you hit your target or not
During my entire military service,
I went to the shooting range 3 times
First time I fired 7 shots, then 10, and then 3
They do not teach you how to shoot
They explain shooting theoretically and
there are huge numbers, difficult to control
It is impossible to explain shooting to
every soldier andtake the time to teach them
No, they do not teach.
They receive an order to go to the shooting range
They have to bring the shells to the commandment
For them it is not important you shoot.
It is important to get bullet shells
If you fire 10 shots and bring back 9 shells
you are in big trouble
The most important thing in the training is the shells
They won’t ask if the soldiers learned how to shoot
no way… the officer would ask:
where are the shells?
A Non Commissioned Officer (NCO)
One time we were training soldiers on shooting
they went to pick up the shells
and there were about 20 cases missing
They spent two hours searching
until they found them
I am the one who will be held accountable
So the most important thing
is to find the missing shells
We did not practice shooting
the way people think we did
shooting while standing up
so we only fired the gun lying down
"For your safety"
Recoil after discharge is hard to handle
so when they shoot while lying down
they can handle it
It is difficult to shoot while standing up,
let alone while moving
An Officer
So a soldier is not trained to do this
End of story, they are not ready
to shoot in a war
only in a firing range
Norvell De Atkine - a U.S. Army retired colonel
Count till 2
left right left
organize your steps
You are supposed to stay
45 days in the warfare center
then take a 10-day break
before joining your unit
We spent 2 months and a half with no breaks
Only to do the show
Every day, we trained on how to march
because we were going to march
in front of important people
every day!
The most important thing
soldiers learn in the first 45 days
or 30 month conscribed reserve officers learn
is how to march so they march
well in the military parade
In a show
20 steps separate each
formation from the other
Clockwise turn
Frankly, in the Reserve Academy, the main goal
is to prepare us for the graduation ceremony
attended by the Minister
and covered by the media
We spend 6 months in the Academy
4 of which – or even more – training for our graduation
how to march, how to move
the rifle, how to do the military show
how to write Egypt or
anything else as we stand.
Special Force individuals
choose certain reserve officers
who used to go to the gym
for example or body builders
and give them special training for these shows
They train them on jumping
over fire pits for example
for the people watching, this is nice
They hear one step, see a synchronized movement
As a show, this coordination is so beautiful
As a show
But as a fighter, it does not benefit you in anything
Will I fight in a parade?
An Officer
Do I call on other soldiers in a war to write Egypt?
or to move the rifle from left to right?
My sacrifice... my sacrifice
You are Egypt leader, and
pioneer of its modern renaissance
We met some very good guys
Each was assigned to a different unit
We were all sad to leave
you know, we were strangers
when we met but close friends when we left
Soldiers gather and they all look confused
they are leaving, their names are being called
A soldier singing
I thought about getting ready
to join them and be one of them
I saw a non-commissioned officer
and a sergeant calling: Attention!
After their training, The soldiers are distributed
to different military units to continue their conscription
As soon as you reach the
gate, you see a security soldier
He looks at everyone and says:
"people will look drunk, but they are not.
But God’s punishment is tough"
He looks at you and he can
see what you will go through
He asks you why you came and
wonders if someone put a curse on you
In general, let it go
An insult does not stick and
government whips are no disgrace
We were forced to get
undressed,stay in our underwear
stand in line and clap on each other’s backs
We joined the battalion and
were told to refer to Officer Adel
they did the paperwork and let us in
As we were standing, Officer Adel
came out of the room in his boxers with a whip
He screamed:
Everyone on the floor! everyone crawl!
They sprayed us with water, threw dirt on us
while we crawled for a reason we ignored
This is the welcoming
They introduce you to your
new status, to who you are
You are nothing
When we joined, they made us love the place
They told us they were men
and they would treat us like men
They said of course they would
encounter some childish behavior
but they would still treat us
like men, raise us to be men
You wake up at five and stand in line to clean
You clean around you.
You remove fallen tree leaves
Every soldier shall have
a cloth bag to clean around them
They shall pick up tree leaves
and put them inside the bag
When there is sand in the field, you level it
After the cleaning line comes the fitness line
You are supposed to run and warm up
But I hereby acknowledge that fitness lines
are the best thing the army has ever created
Work is divided, and you know that
by work I mean daily cleaning chores
The soldier shall clean the walls,
the sinks and the sewage canals with aluminum cables
They shall rub the floors with
a brush and the toilet with the toilet brush
Some mop the floor and
sweep it, others clean the toilets
some clean the sewage disposal canals
tasks that are in no way military
Sometimes we would do unnecessary work
for example today we have to
move this stack of adobe bricks
We would spend 7 to 8 hours moving them
Then the next day we are asked
to bring them back to where they were
You cannot say you do not do
anything in the army, because you do!
My days are so busy
We wake up early and go to bed exhausted at 10 pm
Therefore, we “practice nothingness”
You do not say you do nothing.
This is a lie and a disgrace
You practice nothingness actively!
A rested soldier will tire you,
a tired soldier will ensure you rest
If my soldier is rested, he will tire me
But if I bother him enough, I will be rested
An officer or an NCO could learn you are a carpenter, for example
gives you a day off and take you to fix his house
In my unit, some soldiers went and
painted the Commander’s apartment
All the unit wanted to go to the cafeteria
It belonged to the Brigade Commander.
He had opened a cafeteria near the unit
and soldiers worked there
He had a business for himself
He still ordered the soldiers
to do gardening work in the unit
and he would sell vegetables
I was sent once with the NCO to dig
I had never dug back home.
Why would I dig in the army?
If I was digging a trench for the training, then fine
But to dig so that the Commander
could sell vegetables and make a profit?
I am not here to be a gardener!
Some soldiers who work as drivers
They become drivers for their officers,
and are used for running personal errands.
If the officer is at home and wants to
go to the mall or do something personal
the soldier drives him
Soldiers are a labor force
They are not physically and emotionally
trained to fight in the battlefield
Since there is no war, soldiers practice something else
The men of the Engineering Force
Egypt’s strong arm, implement
large strategic and development projects
Our Armed Forces have been
the support of the civil sector
with superfluous financial, technical and human capacities
and no effect on their fighting ability
This project is launched through
Captain Fighter Mohammed Ramzi Mohammed
Sir… Yes, sir…
management of large projects.
The Engineering Force in the Armed Forces
Supervisor of the project to establish
1056 housing units in Qena Governorate
Project for a permanent headquarters
for the Women National Council
Swimming pools complex for
training juniors in Manshiyat Naser Club
Those who work in these
towns, more precisely constructors
are they from the Engineering Force?
or are they companies similar to
those who built the Suez Canal?
Purely Egyptian private companies.
Neither foreign companies nor armed forces work
When do armed forces interfere or help?
Almost each town has a construction brigade
When a contractor feels there is a delay
and the project will not be completed on time
they resort to this division.
As you have seen, this building was erected from scratch
Our soldiers are champions
The blue overalls are from the battalion
Exactly, in this project, they are the
only ones from our construction division
We are live with Major General Kamel Wazir
Staff Fighter, because this is indeed a fight
You can see our soldiers
cleaning and leveling the sand
so the project looks its best on the launching day
In addition to its participation in development projects
the armed forces have their own commercial
projects which compete with the private sector
The National Service Products Organization (NSPO)
is part of the Armed Forces
It includes several companies in different sectors
industry, agricultural, poultry and livestock production,
contracting and construction,
mining, general and specialized services
NSPO includes gas stations, general and veterinary services
Officers and soldiers serve there
They are assigned to serve at gas stations, water kiosks
they are assigned to provide general services.
they sell, they buy and so on
These are their assignments
I was assigned to a farm with my battalion
When you are a soldier assigned to a farm,
you are like a worker who does not get paid
You work for free
You water the trees, uproot weeds, harvest
work as a porter from dawn till dusk
Usual workers will get paid for that.
But soldiers will not
Plus, you cannot exploit
workers the way you exploit soldiers
Any officer who goes to a military club or
hotel can see how all staff members are soldiers
An Officer
Starting from the porter to the
receptionist, including hotel restaurant staff
They are all soldiers
I served in the field of pastries
I learned how to cut a cake
and how to prepare caramel pudding
this is a military task, isn’t it?
A brigadier general managed the place
A soldier’s salary is 230 or 235 Egyptian pound
The Army Command assigned a soldier to serve here
while Egyptian men could have been working
in this hotel for 2.000 Egyptian pounds
Why should I hire someone for 2.000 pounds
while I can have a soldier for 200?
In a gas station, instead of hiring
someone for 1.500 pounds a month, get a soldier
When soldiers serve in their
units, they get 200 pounds
and if they serve at the
station they get the same amount
Why would I hire someone for
1.500 when I can get a soldier?
The Armed Forces' commercial projects are non-taxable
and no civilian party can have
a financial monitoring over them
Leave the army alone
it is going well. It is a strong institution
Why, sir? Why would we not monitor it?
The People’s Assembly has a National Security Committee
to oversee and monitor the Army’s budget
I will be very honest…
Your silence holds many words
Or he could be thinking
The Army, Mr Ibrahim, is a great institution
beyond any Egyptian’s imagination capacity
When I joined the battalion, we stood in line
we were asked if anyone wanted
to go to the Commander’s office
I said I did
- Come with me, soldier
Mop the floor… wash
my clothes… sweep the floor
get the food ready… prepare a soup…
get me some tea… get me coffee
I became a maid…
in the army it is called "Sika"
A sika is an officer’s personal assistant
They serve the officer directly
they are always at the officer’s
door serving him whatever he wants
If an officer lives nearby,
a sika would run his errands
He might go to buy him some
personal stuff for the house as well
We saw a sika once polishing
the boots of the battalion commander
Well I do not stand in line
I do not feel the sun’s heat.
This is what kept me going
But deep down, I never wanted to be that man
A sika soldier is feared
by his colleagues… why?
Because he is not only a sika,
he is also a little bird
he sits with his colleagues, listens to them
and reports back to the officer
This impression is mostly untrue
It depends on the officer and his assistant
Sometimes the assisting soldier could
serve his colleagues in the battalion
If a soldier needs something,
the assistant could talk to the officer about it
or if someone is in trouble, he
can talk to the officer to let it go
If you do the math, for example
me and two other officers had 3 sikas
The Battalion Commander had 2
The Head of Operations also had 2
These are 7 soldiers in a battalion serving the
officers, Battalion Commander and Head of Operations
In a Brigade, the Brigadier had 6 sikas at his service
One cook, one hairdresser, one to clean and a secretary
If you do the math, for an entire
year in all the brigades in the army
how many sikas can you count
He joined the army and completed his service...
what did you do?
I cooked for the officer… I did the officer’s
laundry… I folded the officer’s clothes
that is all he did in the army
Hey Abdelwadod
you at the border
you order keeper
how are you?
I hope you are well
keep guarding
your mother pray for you
she sends her regards
and she tells you
stay strong as your father
or else they will look down on you
and laugh at you
I tell the Egyptian people
they could see this everyday
and I brought you here to
witness how ready our forces are
and how efficient the unit
to be inspected today is
They enjoy a technical
and a fighting efficiency
Technical efficiency in terms
of weapons and vehicles
and fighting efficiency in terms of
individuals serving in their specialties
When there is an inspection visit
to the brigade or the battalion
We start training them. We train them
how to use weapons and ammunition
so before an inspection visit, it gets busy
There is something in the army
we call "The shot", how it looks
It is not important to have
your gear secure and working
it is more important you make it
look good and well-polished
We would paint our gear about 20 times a year
We had a dedicated unit commander
To impress the Committee of the Ministry of Defense
there were about 500 meters of asphalt separating
the gate from the unit command building
He decided to paint them
He brought the soldiers and we
spent 48 hours painting the asphalt
Colonel General Sodki Sobhi, Chief of Staff of the Armed Forces,
Minister of Defense and Military Production
witnessed the practical demonstration of live
tank shooting by the Armed Forces Artillery Unit
This goes in line with the yearly military training
plan of the Armed Forces divisions and units
Soldiers who attend war simulations
benefit a lot from the army
They are highly trained for combat
But those who are not trained for war
do not receive the same combat training
The best they receive is the shooting training
Do you know how many months a soldier
has to spend practicing for this show?
He spends 3 or 4 months
in a desert, being insulted and tortured
to have those 5 minutes before the
Marshal or the Minister of Defense
or before the Commander
who will come and supervise
The "shot" is everything
Thanks to God, we have a strong Artillery
It is very accurate and able to
perform in a high professional way
The equipment we are trained
to use are called training equipment
They are very old
The equipment we are trained to use and train
our soldiers to use goes back to the 1973 war.
I was a tank aimer
I used to sit in a tank, aim and fire
I handled a T62 tank
I guess it is now a piece in
the Russian military heritage
I aimed and fired
It fell 200 meters away from the target
I fixed the barrel and fired again
It fell 200 meters away, in the same spot
I gave it a thought and calculated the distance
moved the barrel 100 meters away from the target
When I fired, it hit the target!
The Weapons Director was visiting once
When I asked him
he said of course they had Sophisticated weapons
and officers were being
trained elsewhere to use them
Sophisticated weapons, haven’t
you heard of weapon dealsl?
But we cannot use those weapons
to train soldiers. They will ruin them
If you have sophisticated weapons
and you are training trusted officers
and paying them to handle them
why am I was forced to join the
army to train on useless weapons?
You brought me here for nothing
The fighting capacity is
the result of two main factors
the individual and the equipment
Qualified individuals, highly trained for combat
and sophisticated technical equipment
convenient to the soldiers’ capacity,
the battlefield and the nature of the fight
The next day, we were serving
we were assigned to the fortifications
mosquitos were as big as buffalos
ripping through our overalls
hours went by like years
sikas were not loyal
breakfast is served at 6 am
are those beans or rot?
Of course, you suffer from indigestion
but who will care about us?
The officers’ food was
incomparable with the soldiers’
Soldiers’ food was worse than bad
You are stuck with what you
have whether you like it or not
As for officers’ food, it was something else
They had their meals in
a neat and clean place
Some soldiers would get
their revenge from officers
by spitting in their food as they cook it
Every now and then, a commander
comes and sits with us
He asks if we have any complaints
We usually complained about
the bad food and the small quantities
He would say: in every brigade,
there are 3 thousand soldiers
If we spend 1 pound per
soldier on food every day
we would be spending
3.000 pounds a day on one brigade
and 100.000 pounds a month
How many brigades and soldiers do we have?
and our country’s economy is weak;
how should we buy all this food?
That is what he would say
then why bring me to the army in the first place?
Do they do it on purpose to teach soldiers
to eat everything and not to complain about food?
I do not know
If you want me to get
used to eating anything
you should do that in times of training
when we are in a certain psychological state
when we feel we are warriors
and not prisoners whom you
feed anything so they do not object
If soldiers should eat anything,
why is this not the case for officers?
Will they not be together in the battlefield?
We were assigned on duty
that is when we are required to serve
A number of soldiers from
our battalion were assigned
The NCO told the officer who wanted us to
go on duty and who was from another battalion
that it was lunch hour and if it was
possible we have lunch before we go
The officer said they
needed us right away
We were shocked when we realized we
were going to clean the officers’ residence
It was lunch hour, and
the officers were eating
We stood there. They were sitting in
their five-star food court having lunch
as we stared at them، hungry,
waiting to clean after them
One officer was outside.
He was not eating
He saw the soldiers standing
and staring as the officers ate
He screamed: turn!
We did
and by that we turned our
backs to the officers’ food court
so we do not see the officers eating
while we were brought
hungry to clean after them
It was very humiliating
My whole life, I have
never felt as humiliated
In the army, there are officers,
non-commissioned officers
and soldiers
An officer only addresses soldiers
through non-commissioned officers
A non-commissioned officer is
usually a preparatory school graduate
and an army volunteer
There is a saying in the army
when you say “I was thinking”,
they ask you: “thinking?”
Rest your brain
It is common among non-commissioned officers
They are the trainers
They feel they are the
most maltreated in the army
They are not well respected officers
and they are not soldiers
who serve a year and leave
They feel they are wronged
Officers mistreat them and
humiliate them in front of soldiers
and soldiers stand up to them
Non-commissioned officers are the main pillar
which promotes performance in units and formations
Their slogan is: belief, determination, sacrifice
Of course I am staying all my life in the army
I will not be treated like
an officer, and this is unjust
but what can I do?
This is my job
Even people with normal work are fed up
I swear I was a good
student, and I studied well
but I was fed up with
school and dropped out
But this is my job, what can I do?
The relationship of soldiers with
non-commissioned officers is always very bad
They mistreat soldiers,
punish and abuse them
No, we do not torture them
We only punished them when we felt like it
I remember I woke the soldiers up
once at 2 in the morning
It was freezing
I made them stand in line
I ordered them to take their clothes off
They did
You know how difficult it is
to stay naked in the cold
I ordered them to lie down
and sprayed them with water
I made them crawl in the field
For some non-commissioned officers
you can be a university graduate, but they
will always want to prove you are weak
We beat them, mistreat them
until they learn to obey
especially those university graduates
who think they are far better than us
when actually they work as sikas and in offices
They are not qualified for the tough military life
I knew a non-commissioned officer
who would always say:
Do not ever think you are smarter than me
because I am smarter than you
For no reason
No one tried to prove they were smarter than him
He just liked to repeat that
It reassured him
In the army, it is a matter of seniority
Any senior has the
right to give you orders
There are two types of seniors
those who joined before you,
and those with a higher rank
You sense fear everywhere
Soldiers fear NCOs and officers
NCOs fear officers
The army was established on fear
Where does this chain end?
When you can no longer mistreat
your junior because you have none
Soldiers are at the end of the chain
They are subject to all forms of oppression
and stress going through the chain
They absorb them and keep them in
A soldier is like a rubber band
the more pressure you put on it,
the more you control it
Once you let go, it
bounces back at you
Soldiers will not learn
discipline without punishment
Punishment comes in stages
The worst you can do is deprive
a soldier from going on holiday
or refer him to the military court
You can also punish a soldier in the field
make them take the 6th position
The 6th position is the push-up position
You lie down on your stomach
and you crawl for half an hour
There is something they call the grill
You lie down and roll on
the asphalt under the sun
Suffering is not necessarily humiliating
When you are forced to walk for 20 kilometers
you suffer but you become a man
But if when I am walking I say I am
tired and you hit me and curse me
you might think it will make me a man
but in that way you broke me
Obey, then object
If you believe you have been wronged
do as you are told then complain
to a higher ranking officer
For instance, if you see a
shaver thrown in the bathroom
and he orders you to shave with it
you shave and then you complain
If you file a complaint at the military
investigators or the Ministry of Defense
and it went unheeded,
can you imagine what will happen to you?
In the army, we go by two rules:
No cursing, but I can insult you,
and no beating
Insults are known, such as filthy, nasty, ugly
but no one is allowed to curse you
But if you join the army
and live there for a while,
you realize you are always cursed
You have no right to object
New soldiers need to be cursed to be disciplined
In the army, someone cursed my mother
I had never experienced this
He said: you son of a…
it really hurt
I looked at him and he said:
do you have something to say you son of…
He was a brigadier general and I was a soldier
I knew what that meant
I saw with my own eyes, when a brigadier general
wants to address a lieutenant
he orders the colonel to do it
because he does not stoop down
to the level of a lieutenant
let alone a soldier
A soldier is no officer
A soldier for a general
is like an ant for a dinosaur
If a dinosaur steps on
an elephant, it will crush it
An elephant will crush a deer
An ant is crushed by all
In the forest, all animals
crush ants as they move
The colonel gathered us and said:
when I curse you, do not be mad. Why?
For a very simple reason
When I get mad at you,
I have two options
I can either ruin your
dossier and punish you
or I can let the anger
out by cursing you
When you join the unit, I want you
to check your dignity at the door
When you join the army you realize
you can easily get beaten by an officer
and try to complain if you can
You do not realize what full power means
having 30-soldier unit in a desert controlled
by one officer who can do whatever he likes
no limits
One time, an officer hung a soldier by his
feet and ordered other soldiers to pull him
How insulting!
We heard screams coming from
the officer’s office: gather everyone
The unit had to gather and so we did
We had to take our clothes off and stand in line
Why?
Because Al Ahli team lost the championship
The Chief of Operations supported Al Ahli
He was a big fan
Then he punished us when they tied
How great! Getting punished for Al Ahli
The worst punishing tactic for an officer or an NCO
is to prohibit a soldier from taking a day off
This is the worst punishing
method that destroys a soldier
Some soldiers would spend
3 months with no day off
so they would do something very strange
A soldier would tie a bandage around his knee
we call it a tourniquet
to stop the blood flow
then go to sleep
He would wake up with
his leg feeling numb
He would then take something
hard and break his leg with it
Once he breaks it,
he would untie the tourniquet
so the blood flows back to his leg
He would feel unbearable pain
He broke his leg
You cannot forbid him from
taking a month and a half off
You can only imagine how they live
and what they feel when in the battalion
Yes, some soldiers ran away
They went on holiday
and never came back
A soldier ran away because
an officer hung him by his foot
He left and never came back
You join the army with the belief that
it is the worst thing that will happen to you
but you have to go through it
to move on with your life
Of course, some do not
move on with their lives
They commit suicide in the army
A soldier was not given a leave
His mother was dying
and he wanted to see her
The officer did not want to
give him permission to leave
He told him: I will not give you permission,
I do not feel like it
The soldier begged him, please, let me go
He decided to come up
with a plan to escape
He was caught
The officer told him: even if your mother dies,
I will not let you go
His mother passed away while
he was still in the army
He got too mad that he shot the officer
he shot him in his room
here
I remember there was a soldier serving
in the Republican Guard
He got fed up with all the orders and punishing
so he shot the officer and the NCO
Then he shot himself
He committed suicide
I used to read the faxes we received because
I handled operations, organization and management
We mostly received faxes about
soldiers committing suicide
The official reason?
Unheeded instructions and orders stressing
the need for raising religious awareness among soldiers
This is not the real reason
Why would a soldier commit suicide?
Because you are not providing
enough religious education?
No, you are bringing a Sheikh to preach
every Thursday that suicide is Haram
But when the Sheikh leaves,
officers torture and torment soldiers
This leads the soldiers to suicide
Fine, suicide is Haram, but
what about what you are doing? ? Is it not Haram?
All this humiliation, and only suicide is haram?
We believed the army was our spirit breaker
That expression was common
The hardest thing in life is
to have someone control you
Soldiers are the most inferior in the army
I asked an officer once
why we were humiliated all the time
He told me they were training us
on harsh conditions in capture
I said: why don’t you teach us how to fight first,
before you teach us how to behave when captured?
Why do you do it the other way around?
Train me to fight.
I might not be captured  and succeed
The day before we left the army,
before our last day in the unit
we partied so hard.
We spent our day dancing
Dancing and partying was as close as we felt
to the real world and to other people
Within the army,
we build strong friendships
We undergo the same torturing
We stand together because we are all miserable
I served my time and did not learn anything new
I even lost a few things
I suffered from severe psychological issues
Joining the army taught me a lot
I met different people
both good and bad
liars… hypocrites… people who wanted
to manipulate others at any cost…
I have nothing to do with wars,
I know nothing about them
I used to plant and harvest
I have nothing to do with wars
You can find other responsible people in wars...
but not me!
When war erupts, we will die
and others will fight
who are those others and
what will they fight with?
My guess is as good as yours
There’s a common belief in the army
if war erupts, there is another army that will fight
I do not know how to use a weapon
and I have never been trained on tactics
The rifle I was trained to use was made in 1954
I was trained on a 50-year-old rifle
What war are you talking about?!
30 soldiers were killed after two separate
attacks on army points in Northern Sinai
After the death of 27 soldiers in a terrorist attack
that targeted tanks in Karm Alkawadis, south Areish
our reporter informed us that at least 3 others were
killed as a result of an attack on an army checkpoint
Many Egyptian soldiers, NCO and officers were killed by a series
of attacksbetween June 2013 and the screening of the movie
A Film by
Emadeldin Elsayed
Producer
Ahmed Elmasry
Special thanks to all who took part in making this movie
and whose names were not mentioned for safety reasons